hello everyone today we're diving into
amazing figma tips and tricks that will
speed up your workflow and turn you into
a figma wizard if you're interested in
improving your design game even more be
sure to check out our free ux UI design
Playbook you can find the link in the
description below the video now let's
get right into it our first tip involves
using figma's delete and heal function
let's say you want to remove one of the
points in a shape
simply select it and hold down shift
while pressing delete the point
disappears but instead of cutting the
shape figma heals the path automatically
but what about more complex shapes well
let's switch to a line in the shape of a
question mark if your path has too many
points you can select multiple points
and hold down shift while pressing
delete figma will automatically heal the
path and smoothen it
let's move on to our next tip imagine
you're working on a large figma file
with a lot of similar elements like
these shapes or text elements here and
you want to select all of them at once
first you just need to select an element
go to edit and then select all with and
choose the property based on your needs
and just like that all the elements with
the same properties are selected this
feature can be a massive Time Saver
okay let's jump right into the next tip
which is about figma's smart selection
feature let's say you're working with
multiple objects in an array like this
select objects that you want to tidy up
now notice this little grid icon in the
corner just click on it it just
magically tidied up our objects you can
adjust the spacing between them and drag
objects around to rearrange them
the next tip is about adjusting small
and big nudge amounts
by default when you select an object and
use the arrow keys to nudge it it moves
by one pixel if you hold down the shift
key while using the arrow keys your
object will move 10 pixels at a time but
maybe you need to make really precise
adjustments
choose preferences and then nudge amount
there you adjust the nudge amounts so if
you want to move objects by half a pixel
or 0.1 pixel you can do that too
moving on let's explore a unique feature
of figma using images as Styles in figma
you can create Styles not only for
colors text effects and layouts but also
for images click on the four dots next
to fill and then on the plus button here
you can name your style
we'll call it Lake for now and then hit
create style now this image has been
saved as a style and you can apply this
style to any shape or font The Arc tool
is a great tool for creating and
manipulating curves and circles in figma
when you hover over the circle a single
handle will appear on the right hand
side
this point determines where you can
begin to create an arc click and drag
the arc handle up or down to change the
suite this create a gap in the circle
now there will be three handles shown
the ratio handle at the center of the
circle allows you to change the circle
to a ring the start handle indicates
where the arc Begins the sweep indicates
how complete the circle is
the next tip is about using multiple
fills and figma
this can be particularly useful when you
have text overlaying an image and you
want to improve its readability
select your image and in the right hand
panel look for the fill property click
on the plus icon neck to fill to add an
additional fill you can adjust the color
of this fill to create a nice effect we
can also change this fill to a gradient
and adjust the gradient so that the
darker part is near the text
further enhancing its readability the
best part is we did all this without
needing to add additional rectangles or
layers on top of our image next up we
have a tip that can save you a lot of
time what if we want the circle to have
the same look as the star including its
color stroke and stroke width we could
manually adjust these properties one by
one but there's a quicker way first
select the star right click and select
copy properties now select the circle
right click and select paste properties
and just like that the circle inherits
the star's properties including its
color stroke and stroke width alright
moving on to the next tip we're going to
talk about ignoring Auto layout using a
simple key the space bar this is an
incredibly handy trick when you want to
adjust your layout freely despite using
Auto layout simply select an element and
hold down the space bar while moving it
inside Auto layout you'll notice that as
long as you're holding the space bar you
can freely move the element around
ignoring the constraints of the auto
layout
the last tip for today is about figma's
built-in calculator
suppose you're working on a design and
you want to make an object wider by
certain amount of pixels just click on
the width property of the object and
instead of typing a new number type plus
and some number and press enter but it
doesn't stop at basic math like addition
subtraction multiplication and division
you can also use more complex operations
like parentheses for order of operations
and percentages
I hope these figma tips and tricks will
help make your design process smoother
and more efficient
don't forget to hit the like button if
you found this video useful and
subscribe to our channel for more handy
design content